friday edition of pft pm shireen
williams mike florio here with you miles
simmons is going to join us in a while
as we try to figure out the next
destination
of jj watt yes i was wondering earlier
this morning shireen
what are we going to talk about at 5 p.m
eastern on the first friday after the
end of the season
i thought it was going to be the pouncey
twins retiring but we got something a
little more significant today don't we
yeah the pouncey twins kind of took a uh
back seat to mr j.j white mike so uh
yeah we have something to talk about
this is usually the the lightest week of
news and we've had some news to talk
about this week so it should pick up
from here
yeah the penalty twins have to be
irritated to say the least their moment
in the sun lasted for about i don't know
an hour and a half before we got the
news straight from j.j watt and here's
the video he posted earlier today that
let everyone know that after 10 seasons
he would be leaving the houston texans
i have sat down with the mcnair family
and i have asked them for my release
and we have mutually agreed to part ways
at this time
i came here 10 years ago
as a kid from wisconsin who'd never
really been to texas before
and now i can't imagine my life without
texas in it
um
the way that you guys have treated me
besides draft night i mean you guys
booed me on draft night but
every day after that you treated me like
family and i truly feel like you're my
family
since that day i have tried to do
everything in my power to work and earn
your respect
and try and make you proud on and off
the field i'm excited and looking
forward to a new opportunity and i've
been working extremely hard
but at the same time it is
it is always tough to move on and
i just want you guys to know that i love
you i appreciate you i appreciate the
mcnair family for giving me
uh drafting me and giving me my first
opportunity nfl
thank you houston i love you
and there it is and
he said there would be no press
conference he wanted the fans to hear it
straight from him
i just wonder
i wonder who didn't want the press
conference because 10 years
shireen you would think there would be a
gathering and i know it's different in a
pandemic but you would think there would
be
some scenario
where
cal mcnair
nick casario
david culley
maybe a little warm-up routine from jack
easterby maybe a quick five to ten
minute set from him
just to get the crowd
you know comfortable
and have a have a have a real press
conference isn't that amazing that they
didn't do that
yeah it's it's truly unbelievable you
know i grew up in the houston area and
i have friends and family who are season
ticket holders and you look at all the
players who have departed houston over
the last two years from garrett cole to
george springer to russell westbrook to
james harden to deandre hopkins and now
to jj watt and jj watt no doubt is the
biggest of all those names to leave and
there is no press conference we don't
get to hear from them and you do wonder
if it's from the texans the texas have a
new gm they have a new head coach they
haven't coached or been the gm of j.j
watts since he's been there so maybe it
was part of that part of it was probably
also cal mcnair and i assume janice
mcnair would have been there too
in the statement it says that was her
favorite player so i assumed she would
have been there and i also assume that
they didn't want to answer any questions
about uh desean watson and the future of
the organization and where it lies right
now mike because there are a lot of
unanswered questions in houston right
now
but there are ways to deal with that and
if you have a good relationship with the
media if you have
a a great pr director who has the oh
wait they fired her if you have somebody
if you have somebody who can
you know just talk to people ahead of
time and say we want this day to be
about jj watt out of respect to him and
i i just i'm curious whether or not
jj watt didn't want it i i wonder
whether or not he's at his wit's end
shireen with the organization we saw him
tweet last week
in response to the firing of the
equipment manager by presumably jack
easterby and it's possible that jj watts
got the same mindset right now that
desean watson has out of here
and you go back mike to the middle of
the season when he had the argument with
bill o'brien and others in the
organization and the next thing you know
bill o'brien is gone i think that's how
much the organization thought of j.j
watt that when he got in the argument
with bill o'brien that that he was gone
so that to me was a signal
at that point that jj watts days in
houston were numbered and as it turned
out they were and you know you expressed
at the trade deadline that perhaps the
texans may look to trade him somewhere
at the trade deadline they didn't so
they didn't get anything for him and
they cut him and now he gets to pick
where he wants to go and he gets ahead
of free agency mike
yeah and look they weren't gonna bring
him back at a 17 million dollar salary
it was not going to happen we're going
to talk about that more coming up let's
hear a little bit more though from jj
watt his press conference from week 16
where it was becoming more and more
clear he was exasperated with the effort
or lack thereof of the individuals who
were around him on that roster here he
is
you can't go out there and you can't
work out you can't show up on time you
can't practice you can't want to go out
there and win you shouldn't be here
because this is a privilege it's the
greatest job in the world you get to go
out and play a game
and if you can't care enough even in
week 17 even when you're trash when
you're 4 and 11 if you can't care enough
to go out there and give everything
you've got and try your hardest
that was a very very inspiring and
motivating effort from j.j watt and it
was obvious he was becoming
frustrated to say the least with what
was going on and we already knew
i think he wasn't going to be back we
knew
that this was going to be and what
surprised me and i'm going to go ahead
and jump right into it shireen it
surprised me that they let him go
without trying
to trade him it would have been
difficult
but
33 days
in advance of free agency he gets that
head start they didn't try to go to him
and say look we have you under contract
for one more year we'd like to work
something out where maybe we get a sixth
or seventh round pick and you agree to
reduce salary and we find the team and
we'll we'll contact whoever you want
we'll let your agent set it up we just
like to we'd like to get something in
return for what we're giving up here
otherwise we're going to wait until
march 17 to release you
teams do that all the time last year the
panthers released tight end greg olsen
right after the super bowl they held on
to cam newton into late march because
they thought maybe they could get
something for him as he was entering the
last year of his contract that kind of
surprised me and you know at a time when
there isn't a whole lot of goodwill
floating around the texans organization
that probably is something that we could
look at and say hey they did the guy a
favor they did the guy a solid they did
the guy something
that they didn't have to do
and uh
you don't see that from a lot of teams
because teams have their contractual
rights and teams try to turn them into
anything that sixth round pick could
have become a hall of famer i mean tom
brady was a sixth round pick i know it's
rare that that happens but those picks
have value and i'm just surprised they
didn't try to to flip the remaining year
of the contract into something and
instead gave him that head start on free
agency
but are you really surprised mike i mean
we are talking about the use of texans
right
well
yeah look i as we've established
whenever there's a decision that they
can make that is not the right decision
that is the decision they will make but
it does engender some good will with jj
watt and who knows maybe jj watt made it
clear to them you're gonna let me go now
or i'm gonna use my social media
platforms to just hammer you repeatedly
until you do because i know and you know
you're not going to carry a 17 million
dollar salary
under my name going into a new league
year that quite possibly will have
a dramatically reduced salary cap so
it was at some level in their interest
if jj watt made it clear that he was not
going to be publicly quiet like the
other high-profile texan who wants out
of houston deshaun watson has chosen to
be watson has handled his business
behind the scenes with no direct
statement or plea to be traded maybe j.j
watt and maybe that tweet from last week
was just a taste of what jj watt was
going to do if they didn't let him out
of houston and it's not like any texans
fans would have been upset with him the
texans fan understand what a
dysfunctional mess it is right now in
houston cal mcnair spoke to just a
couple of reporters i think adam
schefter and ian rappaport and he said
this and uh
well this this is a desean well i'm
going to pivot to deshaun watson since
we're talking about him um
there's a lot of misinformation out
there i'll leave it at that that's what
cal mcnair said about desean watson
today we want to focus on jj deshawn is
our quarterback he is a texan we expect
him to remain a texan and we'll leave it
at that and sharing that that
amplifies the point you made earlier no
matter what they may have done
to try to make a press conference only
about
jj watt there was no way this was going
to be only about jj watt
this truly hangs over the organization
mike uh the desean watson situation and
they're gonna bungle that some way and
you know i would love to give the texans
credit for this i hope it truly was just
doing the right thing for j.j white mike
he has meant so much to that city so
much that organization but so much to
the city as much as the organization
it's why he won the walter payton man of
the year award raised over 40 million
dollars for hurricane harvey relief and
my family was in hurricane harvey i know
what that meant for the city of houston
and surrounding areas that was huge he
has meant a ton to this organization
and and no one will replace jj watt ever
again he's the greatest defensive player
perhaps the greatest player in the
organization's history so far and it is
a 19-year history so it's not like that
long mike but i i want to believe that
the texans did the right thing
by j.j watt and that's all it was but
you know the cynic in me knowing the
texans history and i realize bill
o'brien is gone but some of the other
key players are still there says they
didn't do the right thing in trying to
get a draft pick because you just go
back and you look at all the trades that
they've bungled in their history from
dwayne brown to jadavion county to
deandre hopkins to giving up a draft
pick for duke third round pick for duke
johnson i mean this is an organization
that hasn't proved that it knows
how to draft how to compile draft picks
or any of that mike they've just they've
bungled everything over the last few
years and organization in the nfl and
perhaps the worst organization in sports
right now
i was on radio earlier this afternoon
1067 the fan in dc and
the the question came up as it relates
to the timeline for a desean watson
decision we had a question earlier this
week about the timeline and that
presumes that they know what's good for
them i don't know that they know what's
good for them and and and that's i'm
having such a hard time with this jj
watt decision because was it good for
them
to cut him with 33 days to go into a
free agency or was it good for them to
hold on to him and try to work out some
sort of a trade we've heard nothing to
suggest that they tried in advance to
work something out i just think they
were afraid that jj was going to come at
them with everything he had if they
didn't let him go and they blinked they
didn't want to get into a fight with
captain america because here's the other
side of it too
yeah yeah jj watt gets a an advance
start on free agency but
until we know what the salary cap's
going to be for 2021 it's going to be
hard for him to get full value because
he's going to fall into that group
of veteran players who aren't star level
who are going to get squeezed if the cap
goes down so until we know what the cap
is going to be
you can't peg
what j.j watt's value is going to be
he's a lot like the andama consu
conundrum i had a gm tell me look last
year sue got eight million you get sue
on the market this year he's not getting
eight million not not just because he's
a year older the the the dominicans from
2020 on the market this year is getting
a lot less because those are the guys
who are going to get hurt by a flat or
likely depressed salary cap so those 33
days may just be
a lot of talking and visiting
and and just
general concepts and and
identification of who's interested but
ultimately no hard offers
until teams have a better idea of what
the cap is going to be
and when you look mike at what j.j watt
has said specifically publicly he was
fed up with this organization there is
no question about that throughout the
year all of his comments i mean he was
even short in one press conference with
john mclean of the houston chronicle our
friend who we know good and well
that jj has a lot of respect for so he
was fed up with that organization going
back into the middle season i think he
was fed up with losing it is not going
to surprise me if at some point we hear
that jj watt went above cal mcnair even
into cal mcnair's mother janice mcnair
and appealed to her and said
janice do me a solid here i want to be
cut i want to go try to find another
team
let me go now and janice ordered this uh
to happen it's like a surprised me to
all mike if that happened and the
organization did do him a solid but he
might have gone to janice mcnair above
everybody else in that organization to
ask for this to be done
well you know i joked when it first
happened hey all that deshawn watson has
to do is ask to be released because
apparently that's the way you get out
don't ask for a trade ask to be released
and you get what you'll want and look i
posted a tweet earlier today and i it
was part part sociological experiment
and part expression of absolute fact
watson has gotten crickets in response
to his request for a trade what asks to
be released and they immediately let him
go
there is
i look i i know it's different
situations it's apples and oranges it's
a a young ascending quarterback and an
aging descending defensive lineman who
they're likely going to cut but the idea
that they did something they didn't have
to do
for what
and could have tried to trade him and
could have squatted on him for another
month and chose not to that's the
distinguishing characteristic for what
they did something they didn't have to
do for watson
they've given no indication that they're
willing to do something they don't have
to do
yeah no question about it mike and we'll
see how the deshaun watson situation
plays out i have a feeling they're gonna
bungle that too with the people i've
talked to within the organization
they're gonna sit on deshaun watson they
are now telling teams we're not trading
deshaun watson he's gonna hold out this
is gonna go beyond
the draft and they're not gonna get what
they could have otherwise gotten for
them i i believe that's going to happen
i have no doubt in my mind that's going
to happen that they're going to have a
standoff and this is going to come to a
head after deshaun watson holds out at
that point mike once you once you pass
draft time teams have their quarterbacks
they're set what are you going to do at
quarterback how are you going to get
this guy traded for what he should go
for which at a minimum as we've said is
three first-round draft picks
and you know the talk has been that he's
very serious about this this isn't a
bluff this isn't huffing and puffing he
is indeed going to never play for the
texans again and will hold out into the
regular season and if he has to give
back money so be it he's a guy who comes
from nothing he's not afraid of having
to write a check back to the texans
because he still will have a lot more
than he otherwise would have had and uh
his mind was made up and and i think
that's why he waited to use the magic
phrase please trade me because he knew
what the implication was and he knew
that if he did it he was locked into a
course of action that there would be no
turning back from and i respect the fact
that
he's willing to do that and isn't going
to be the guy who shows up and just
decides to be a problem and decides to
say my ankle hurts or my back hurts or i
have a pooled hamstring or i can't
practice today or i'm just going to be a
problem until you trade me he's not
wired that way and i'm not passing
judgment against the guys who choose
that path i just think that for him if
it's more comfortable if it's better if
it's the right thing for him to do to
just never show up again then then
that's his decision that's his choice
and he's a big boy he understands the
consequences of that and it sounds like
he's willing to take them
boy this has been crazy mike how far
this organization has fallen in such a
short amount of time you think about all
the players they had on this team from
jadavion clowney to deandre hopkins to
jj watt deshaun watson wants out i mean
they had a real chance to win a
championship and they failed to get it
done which is one reason that jj watts
out of there now mike if you lose to
sean watson you've got even less of a
chance to do that over the next few
years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports